♪ [music] ♪
- [male] We are the paradoxical ape,
bi-pedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly, we hand
down knowledge, we empathize and deceive,
we shake the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Evelina] Thanks very much for having me
here. So today I will tell you about the
language system and some of its properties
that may bear in the question of how the
system came about. I will begin by
defining the scope of my inquiry because
people mean many different things by
language. I will then present you some
evidence and suggesting that our language
system is highly specialized for language
and finally I will speculate a bit on the
evolutionary origins of language. So
linguistic input comes in through our ears
or our eyes and once it's been analyzed
perceptually, we interpret it by linking
the incoming representations to our
language knowledge and this knowledge, of
course, is also used for generating
utterances during language production. And
once we've generated an utterance in our
heads, we can send it down to our
articulation system and the part that I
focus on is this kind of high level
component of language processing. This
cartoon shows you the approximate
locations of the brain regions that
support speech perception shown in yellow,
visual letter and word recognition in
green, this region is known as the visual
word form area, articulation in pink and
high level language processing in red.
And what differentiates the high level
language processing regions from the
perceptual and articulation regions, is
that they're sensitive to the
meaningfulness of the signal. So for
example, the speech regions will respond
just as strongly to foreign speech as they
respond to meaningful speech in our
language. The visual word form area
responds just as much to a string of
consonants as it does to real words, the
articulation regions can be driven to a
full extent by people producing
meaningless sequences of syllables. But in
contrast, the high level language
processing system or network, or sometimes
I refer to it just as the language network
for short, cares deeply about whether the
linguistic signal is meaningful or not. In
fact, the easiest way to find the system
in the brain is to contrast responses to
meaningful language stimuli like words,
phrases or sentences and some control
conditions like linguistically degraded
stimuli. The contrast I've used most
frequently is between sentences and
sequences of non-words.
A key methodological innovation that laid
the foundation for much of my work was the
development of tools that enable us to
define the regions of the language network
functionally of the individual subject
level using contrasts like these, and here
I'm showing you sample language regions in
three individual brains. And this
so-called functional localization approach
has two advantages one, it circumvents the
need to average brains together which is
what's done in the common approach and
it's a very difficult thing to do because
brains are quite different across people.
And instead in this approach, we can just
average the signals that we extract from
these key regions of interest. And the
second advantage is that it allows us to
establish accumulative research
enterprise, which I think we all agree is
important in science. Because comparing
results across studies in labs is quite
straight forward if we're confident that
we are referring to the same brain regions
across different studies. And this is just
hard or impossible to do in the
traditional approach which relies on very
coarse anatomical landmarks like the
inferior frontal gyrus or the superior
temporal sulcus which span many
centimeters of cortex and they're just not
at the right level of analysis.
So what drives me in my work is the desire
to understand the nature of our language
knowledge and the computations that
mediate language comprehension and
production, however these questions are
hard specially given the lack of any
models for language. And so for now I
settle on more tractable questions for
example one, what is the relationship
between the language system and the rest
of human cognition? Language didn't evolve
and it doesn't exist in isolation from
other evolutionarily older systems, which
include the memory and attention
mechanisms, the visual and the motor
systems, the system that supports social
cognition and so on. And that means that
we just can't study language as an
isolated system. And a lot of my research
effort is aimed at trying to figure out
how language fits with the rest of our
mind and brain. And the second question
delves inside the language system asking,
what does its internal architecture look
like? And it encompasses questions like:
what are the component parts of the
language system and what is the division
of labor among them in space and time?
And of course, both of those questions
ultimately should constrain the space of
possibilities for how language actually
works. So they place constraints on both
the data structures that underlie language
and the computations that are likely
performed by the regions of the system.
And today, I focus on the first of these
questions. Okay, so now onto some
evidence. So the relationship between
language and the rest of the mind and
brain has been long debated and the
literature actually is quite abundant with
claims that language makes use of the same
machinery that we use for performing other
cognitive tasks including arithmetic
processing, various kinds of executive
function tasks, perceiving music,
perceiving actions, abstract conceptual
processing and so on. And I will argue
that these claims are not supported by the
evidence.
Two kinds of evidence speak to the
relationship between language and other
cognitive systems, there is brain imaging
studies, brain imaging evidence and
investigations of patients with brain
damage. In fMRI studies, we do something
very simple we find our regions that seem
to respond a lot to language and then we
ask how do they respond to other various
none linguistic tasks. And if they don't
show much of a response, then we can
conclude that these regions are not
engaged during those tasks. And in the
patient studies we can evaluate
non-linguistic abilities in individuals
who don't have a functioning language
system and if they performed well, we can
conclude that the language system is not
necessary for performing those various
non-linguistic tasks. So starting with
fMRI evidence, I will show you responses
in the language regions to arithmetic,
executive function tasks and music
perception today. So here are two simple
regions, a region in the inferior frontal
cortex around Broca's area and the region
in the posterior middle temporal gyrus,
but the rest of the regions of this
network look similar in their profiles.
And the region on the top is kind of in
and around this region knows as Broca's
area except I don't use that term because
I don't think it's a very useful term.
In black and gray I show you the responses
to the two localized condition sentences
and non-words, and these are estimated and
data that's not used for defining these
regions, so we divide the data in half,
use half of the data to define the regions
and then the other half to quantify their
responses. I will now show you how these
regions respond when people are asked to
do some simple arithmetic additions,
perform a series of executive functions
tasks like for example hold a set of
locations in spatial memory, spatial
locations in working memory or perform
this classic flanker tasks, or listen to
various musical stimuli.
For arithmetic and various executive tasks
we, included a harder and an easier
condition because we wanted to make sure
that we can identify regions that are
classically associated with performing
these tasks, which is typically done by
contrasting a harder and an easier
condition of a tasks. So I'll show you now
in different colors responses to these
various tasks, starting with the region on
the lower part of the screen. So we find
that this region doesn't respond during
arithmetic processing, doesn't respond
during working memory, doesn't respond
during cognitive control tasks and doesn't
respond during music perception. And quite
strikingly to me at the time, a very
similar profile is observed around this
region which is smack in the middle of the
so-called Broca's area, which appears to
be incredibly selective in its response
for language.
And know that it's not just the case that
these, for example, demanding tasks fail
to show a hard versus an easy difference.
They respond pretty much at or below
fixation base line when people are engaged
in these tasks, so that basically tells
you that these language regions work as
much when you're doing a bunch of math in
your head or hold information in working
memory as what you're doing when you're
looking at a blank screen, so they really
do not care. So of course, to interpret
the lack of the response in these language
regions, you want to make sure that these
tasks activate the brain somewhere else
otherwise you may have really bad tasks
that you don't want to use.
So indeed they do. So here I'll show you
activations for the executive functions
tasks, but musical also robustly activates
the brain outside of the language system.
So here are two sample regions one in the
right frontal cortex, one in the left
parietal cortex and you see the profiles
of response are quite different from the
language regions. For each task we see
robust responses, but also a stronger
response to the harder than the easier
condition across these various domains,
and these regions turn out to be part of
this bilateral front to parietal network
which is known in the literature by many
names including the cognitive control
network or the multiple demand system, the
letter term advanced by John Duncan who
wanted to highlight the notion that these
regions are driven by many different kinds
of cognitive demands.
And so these regions appear to be
sensitive to effort across tasks and their
activity has been linked to a variety of
goal directed behaviors. Interestingly, if
you look at the responses of these regions
to our language localizer conditions, we
find exactly the opposite of what we find
in the language regions, they respond less
to sentences than sequences of non-words
presumably because processing sentences
requires less effort, but clearly this
highlights again the language and the
cognitive control system are clearly
functionally distinct. Moreover, damage to
the regions of the multiple demand network
has been shown to lit to decreases in
fluid intelligence. So Alex Woolgar and
colleagues have reported a strong
relationship between the amount of tissue
loss in frontal and parietal cortices and
a measure of IQ, and this is not true for
tissue loss in the temporal lobes. And
it's quite striking, you can actually
calculate for this many cubic centimeters
of loss in the MD system you lose so many
IQ points, it's a strong clear
relationship. So this system is clearly an
important part of the cognitive arsenal of
humans because the ability to think
flexibly and abstract and to solve a new
problems are exactly. . .these are the
kinds of abilities that IQ tests aim to
measure are considered kind of one of the
hallmarks of human cognition.
Okay, so as I mentioned the complimentary
approach for addressing questions about
language specificity and relationship to
other mental functions is to examine
cognitive abilities in individuals who
lack a properly functioning language
system. And most telling are cases of
global aphasia, so this is a severe
disorder which affects pretty much the
entire frontal temporal language system
typically due to a large stroke in the
middle cerebral artery and lead to
profound defecits in comprehension and
production. And Rosemary Varley at UCL has
been studying this population for a few
years now and with her colleagues, she has
shown that actually these patients seem to
have preserved abilities across many many
domain, so she showed that they have
intact arithmetic abilities they can
reason causally, they have good non-verbal
social skills, they can navigate in the
world, they can perceive music and so one
and so forth.
And of course, these findings are then
consistent with the kind of picture that
emerges in our work in fMRI. Let's
consider another important non-linguistic
capacity which a lot of people often bring
up when I tell them about this work. How
about the ability to extract meaning from
non-linguistic stimuli, right? So given
that our language regions are so sensitive
to meaning, we can ask how much of that
response is due to the activation of some
kind of abstract conceptual representation
that language may elicit rather than
something more language specific, semantic
representation type. So to ask these
questions, we can look at how language
regions respond to non-verbal meaningful
representations, in one study we had
people look at events like this or the
sentence level descriptions of them and
either we had them do kind of a high level
semantic judgment task like decide whether
watering a plant is plausible or do a very
demanding perceptual control task. And
basically what you find. . .here's again
the black and gray area responses to the
localizer conditions. So in red as you
would expect, you find strong responses to
the condition where people see sentences
and make semantic judgments on them. So
what happens when people make semantic
judgments on pictures?
We find that some regions don't care at
all about those conditions and other
regions show reliable responses, but
they're much weaker than those elicited by
the meaningful sentence condition. So
could it be that some of our language
regions are actually abstract semantic
regions? Perhaps. But for now, keep in
mind that the response to the sentence
meaning condition is twice stronger and it
is also possible that participants maybe
activating linguistic representations to
some extent when they encounter meaningful
visual stimuli. So to answer this question
more definitive, we are turning to the
patient evidence again. If parts of the
language system are critical for
processing meaning in non-linguistic
representations, then aphasic individuals
should have some difficulties with
non-verbal semantics. First, I want to
share a quote with you from Tom Lubbock, a
former art critic at The Independent, who
developed a tumor in the left temporal
lobe which eventually killed him.
And as the tumor progressed and he was
losing his linguistic abilities he was
documenting his impressions of what it
feels like to lose the capacity to express
yourself using verbal means. So he wrote,
"My language to describe things in the
world is very small, limited. My thoughts
when I look at the world are vast,
limitless and normal, same as they ever
were. My experience of the world is not
made less by lack of language but is
essentially unchanged. " And I think this
quote quite powerfully highlights the
separability of language and thought. So
in work that I'm currently collaborating
on with Rosemary Varley and Nancy
Kanwisher, we are evaluating the global
aphasic's performance on a wide range of
tasks requiring you to process meaning in
a non-verbal stimuli. So for example, can
they distinguish between real objects and
novel objects that are matched for low
level visual properties? Can they make
plausibility judgments for visual events?
What about events were plausibility is
conveyed simply by prototypicality of the
roles? So you can't do this task by simply
inferring that a watering can doesn't
appear next to an egg very frequently,
right. And it seems like the data so far
are suggesting that they indeed seem fine
on all of these tasks and they laugh just
like we do when we see these pictures
because they are sometimes a little funny,
so they seem to process these just fine.
So this suggests to me that these kinds of
tasks can be performed without a
functioning language system. And so, even
if our language system stores some
abstract conceptual knowledge in some
parts of it, it tells me at least that
that code must live somewhere else as
well. So even though if we lose our
linguistic way to encode this information,
we can have access to it elsewhere.
So to conclude this part, fMRI and patient
studies converge and suggest that the
frontal temporal language system is not
engaged in and is not needed for
non-linguistic cognition. Instead, it
appears that these regions are highly
specialized for interpreting and
generating linguistic signals. So just a
couple minutes on what this means. So
given this highly selective response to
language stimuli that we observe, can we
make some guesses already about what these
regions actually do? I think so. I think a
plausible hypothesis is that this network
houses our linguistic knowledge, including
our knowledge of the sounds of the
language, the words, the constraints on
how sounds and words combine with one
another. And then essentially the process
of language interpretation is finding
matches between the pieces of the input
that are getting in to our language system
and our previously stored representations.
And language production is just selecting
the relevant subset of the representations
to then convey to our communication
partner. And this-- And in the form that
this knowledge takes is a huge question in
linguistic psychology in neuroscience, so
one result I don't have time to discuss is
that contra some claims,
it doesn't seemed to be the case of
syntactic processing is localized to a
particular part of this language system.
It seems it's widely distributed across
and anywhere throughout the system you
find sensitivity to both word level
meanings and compositional aspects of
language which is much in line with Ulcher
and linguistic theorizing which doesn't
draw a sharp boundary between the lexicon
and grammar. So this way of thinking about
the language system as a store of our
language knowledge, makes it pretty clear
that the system is probably not innate. In
fact, it must arise via experience with
language as we accumulate this language
store. It's also presumably dynamic,
changing all the time as we get more and
more linguistic input through our
lifetimes. And I assume that our language
knowledge is plausibly acquired with
domain-general statistical learning
mechanisms just like much other knowledge.
So what changed in our brains that allowed
for the emergence of this system? So one
thing that changed is that our association
cortices expanded, so these are regions
that are not sensory and motor regions and
include frontal temporal and parietal
regions. Okay, so these people have noted
for a long time. And I think I'm kind of
in the camp of people who think that our
brains are not categorically different in
any way they're just scaled up versions of
other primate brains, I think there's
quite good evidence for that. And so, how
does the system emerge? So I think one
thing that was different between us and
chimps is that there is a protracted
course to the brain development in humans.
So between birth and adulthood our brains
increase threefold compared to just
twofold in chimps it's a big difference.
And basically this just makes us
exceptionally susceptible to environmental
influences and we can soak stuff up for
the environment very very easily. So as
our brains grow we make more glial cells,
we make more synapses our axioms continue
to grow and become melanated and it's
basically tissue that's ready to soak up
the regularity that we see in the world.
And of course, it comes at a cost that's
why we have totally useless babies that
can't do anything. But apparently somehow
it was worth-- the trade-offs were worth
it.
Okay, so the conclusions. As you know, we
have this system, it's highly selective in
its reposes. It presumably emerges over
the course of our development and what
enabled it is probably some combination of
the expansion of this association cortices
where we can store vast amounts of
symbolic information and this protracted
brain development which makes us great
learners early on. Thank you.
[applause]
♪ [music] ♪